All right. Welcome to
the DDPS seminar, everyone.
Before we introduce our invited
speaker, let's go over some
rules as usual. First of all,
please mute yourself during the
talk. If you have immediate
questions, you're welcome to
unmute and ask or otherwise,
please use the chat room to post
your questions, so that we can
address them in the q&a session
at the end. Second, today's
seminar is open to external
audience, so no classified
discussion is allowed. Finally,
the talk will be recorded and
uploaded to our YouTube channel.
Now, let me introduce our
speaker. It is an honor to host
Eduardo Gildin, who is currently
a professor of petroleum
engineering at the Texas A&M
University, and is the holder of
the LF Peters and forensics
professorship in petroleum
engineering. He received his PhD
from potestas of the University
of Texas at Austin in aerospace
engineering and has held
postdoctoral positions with Rice
University and UT Austin. His
research has been supported by
grants from NSF, DOD, DOD, NSA
and industry, with main topics
in physics based and data
driven, reduced order modeling,
for reservoir simulation, and
optimization, and truly modeling
control and automation. He was
inducted into the SPE
distinguished membership in
2021. Today, he will talk about
guided deep learning manifold
linearization of porous media
flow equations for digital twin
operations. Please enjoy the
wonderful talk. Now without
further ado, let me hand it to
not agree with him by asking a
random question. So where is the
place that you like the most in
Brazil?
I'll say my, my home country, my
home city, San Paolo.
Like for flat patients and
sunlight?
Well, I mean, as people say, in
Brazil, you gotta go to Rio de
Janeiro during the day, and some
Paulo during the night. So
that's
good. So the stage is now rose.
Okay, thanks so much. Thank you,
thank you tonic for the nice
introduction. Thank everyone for
joining my, my seminar. It's,
it's a pleasure and honor to be
here. And I know I've been
watching many of those, the DDPS
seminars myself, and I really
liked it. And you guys are doing
really great on that spectrum.
So let me talk a little bit
about what I've been doing in
the last few years. My
researcher and mod reduction has
been going on for many, many
years now. But we are moving a
little bit on the, you know,
trying to put things on a
digital twin perspective. And
I'm gonna show to you a couple
of things that we are doing, I
will start out with a the idea
of digital twin, at least from a
drilling prospective drilling
engineering perspective, and
we're going to move on to
reservoir engineering. So that
we set the stage for what I mean
by digital twins operation. This
is a joint work, at least under
the visualizations and the
digital twin framework with a
Gentile from the visualization
department and the know the
machine learning scientific
machine learning with Elizabeth
Raghunatha, from Electrical
Engineering here at a&m and many
other my students, you know, I
know many of the the work that
I'm going to principally be
presenting is from Emilio, who
is now at Petrobras in Brazil,
Marcela, who is now at Exxon,
Mobil. Narendra, there is a
McKinsey and Enrique, there's a
postdoc here and Levi, that's a
postdoc, as well with a Docker
Braga, Neto and other students
are being been working on on
that. Okay, so, I'm not going to
spend too much time on the why
we're doing this, I think this
seminar series, at least from
what we are watching here, that
explains really well why model
reduction and other things are
important. But for my
perspective, we are going to a
new wave of, you know,
implementations of porous media
flow. And and, you know, given
that, you know, there is CCUS,
hydrogen storage, geothermal,
and even hydrocarbon production,
right, you know, the net zero
emissions paradigm. It's
important, but we all know that,
you know, in some ways,
petroleum engineers on the
subsurface and that's a quote
that I get from a faculty here
at a&m, who is very much into a
subsurface as well. So, that's
why we still keep into doing
what, what I'm doing on on the
subsurface flows, okay, but
there is a commonality between
all these issues here on the can
be CCUS, geothermal hydrocarbon
or hydrogen storage. As you may
know, they all have a, you know,
a certainty related to
everything. Not only technical,
political, economical, but
everything that we do in that
Rearm, right. And they are all
part of a family of large scale
simulation problems, right, we
are using somehow a subsurface
flow simulation for prediction.
And they are computationally
expensive. And not only that,
it's not about only simulating,
but it's about getting an
answer, and an answer meaning a
fast and robust way to obtain an
optimized answer whatever
optimize mean, I'm not going to
the optimization process itself
here in my talk. But no
optimization can mean minimize
risks can be increased storage
for co2, for instance,
production and anything that you
want. But the problem is that we
are calling this simulator many,
many times you need the know, a
way to know to get a fast answer
out of that. Okay, so that's the
idea here. And not only that,
one interesting article that was
posted in JpT. was, you know, a
couple of years ago, and you can
say that it's a little it's a
little bit old. Yeah, already.
But now they talk a little bit
about, you know, the deal, one
way to solve the issues, using,
you know, moving forward with
this transition, it is that
we're going to have to digitize
a lot more the operations of
things that we do nowadays,
right. And that's why I moved on
to elaborate on the digital twin
concept, and energy, which is
not new. Right? If you look at,
you know, there was a paper
published in 2018 that actually
talk about the last 10 years
now, back then the last 10 years
of a digital twin in energy.
Right, and, you know, back then,
we're mostly on replication of
platforms and the operation
itself. Annotated. Okay. So
something popped up here from
annotation, I don't know what
what is that? But anyway. So. So
even for turbines and
everything, so the digital twin
concept is not new. Right. So
let me show what are we actually
doing on that reel? Okay. The
problem that happens, and the
last 510 years is that, you
know, what I joined a&m 13 years
ago, I used to see it on many of
the industry board meetings. And
faculty used to complain a lot
that the companies wouldn't give
data, right? We don't have data,
we don't have data. Now we have
a new problem, right, which is
that the companies actually
everybody wants to give data.
And we don't know what to do
with that data. So the old
rhetoric that we don't have
enough data may not apply
anymore. And you can see that,
you know, in drilling
operations, we are getting no
information on the beat. And
this is a Halliburton Cerebro
drill bit that you can get, you
know, accelerometers and other
measurements directly on the
beat with 1000 hertz of
frequency. Right. So it's a lots
of data, we have a de distribute
acoustic and distribute
temperature sensing that you
have gigabytes of data,
terabytes of data being shipped
to the along the well, right.
And we don't know what to do
with this, this data, right. So
somehow, we need a some form of
data reduction, model reduction
and a combination of those
things to actually implement
things on the digital twin
framework. Let me let me just
give you a glimpse of one thing
that we are doing on the
drilling side, then we're going
to move on to the reservoir
side. And that's a joint work
with a Gentile, the one that I
mentioned before, and that where
we tried to do a digital twin
for drilling optimization
problems. Okay. Not going to go
into details on the drilling
itself. But basically, we have a
drilling machine right here. And
we still have, you know, the
problem is very complicated,
prohibitively expensive to
simulate everything. So while we
are focusing, we're focusing on
the drill bit DBH a simulation
here. Okay, so just think about
that we are right at this tip of
this drill bit, right. And of
course, we have data from
information from logs
information from how the
structure of the geological
media works, and we're going to
try to employ a digital twin to
recreate environment and the
platform for Good morning. Okay,
so that's, and as I mentioned,
we're going to just focus on the
BHA, right, the PHA. So we are
modeling this in the this BHA
framework. So let me show you a
quick video, if it is, pops up,
hopefully will have our digital
twin implementation for drilling
optimization. And that's
basically a real time drilling
operation. In getting real time
data from a system, we have
here, a miniaturized drilling
machine. So that's where we get
real time data. Right. But
anyway, so I did the focus here
is not drilling, per se. So let
me just close this and move on,
hopefully. Let me just close
this and move on to this one.
And basically, what we
implemented here is a
reinforcement learning for, you
know, trajectory, steering on on
this drilling, drilling machine.
Okay, so there's a paper coming
up. But the nice thing about
that we can optimize and
everything. But as I said, the
problem is not drilling per se.
And the thing is that drilling
is this a small part of these
digital twin operations that we
want to do, right, I'm going to
for the interest of time, I'm
going to come back to this in
the end, if I have time, I'm
gonna show the trajectories late
later in the end. But the idea
is that in real time operations,
we want to put together not only
the drilling itself, right, we
want to put together a reservoir
characterization model, we want
to put together first reservoir
simulation model. And we want to
have a certainty associated with
that as well. Right? So it says
it's a much more complicated
problem just does go into a game
like and if you look at what
we've done, we will use a game
ancient framework, right? To
develop our, our digital twin
for drilling, but for reservoir,
that's a different story, right?
There's a little bit more
complication going from a
simulation of these this entire
loop, right. Okay. So, but in my
perspective, right, we already
have something or a digital a
reservoir simulator is a digital
twin by nature, right? If you
look at what we are doing in the
digital twin, right, we are
replicating the effect of a
certain things, right, with real
time data. And, and the problem
with a reservoir simulation to
become a digital twin is exactly
that digital twin requires real
time data integration into these
built environment. And if you
look at this problem here, this
is a Unison benchmark from a
Brazilian University Unicamp.
One can take a look at, but if
you look at just to this small
problem here, right, we have a
bout, you know, a 1 billion of
states, right? What I mean
pressures and saturations and
concentrations, and so on and so
forth. Right? With, you know, if
you're going to optimize with
about 1500 variables to
optimize, so we need to do
something else with that, that
simulation to became to be able
to do a digital twin framework.
And there's enablers that does
that, it is exactly model
reduction and data driven
modeling, at least in my
perspective, right. So, so, let
me let me let let me, let me go
to that direction. Now. Let me
show what we're doing to do this
model reduction or reservoir
simulation perspective. And I, I
know, suffice to say that, you
know, you know, reservoir
simulation is a is a hard thing
to do. And as I mentioned,
you're looking at a couple
partial differential equations,
lots of states variables, lots
of control variables, and so
forth. Okay. Let me just, you
know, this slide here serves for
you to know, what are the states
that we're looking at pressures
and saturations for this
reservoir, okay. But as far as
the output goes, right, one,
look at all your rates or water
rates that you can do no co2
rates, and so forth. And
usually, this is handled by
what's called peace of mind
equation here. It's a semi
empirical equation right here.
And that's one part of the issue
that we're going to try to solve
later on in my slide, it is how
we handle actually this output.
Okay, this output with the most
of the model reduction
techniques that are out there,
they only look at state, right,
they never looked at the output
by itself. And if you're going
to couple days with a an
optimizer, output is the most
important thing that one has to
look at. Okay, so just keep that
in perspective. So what is the
model reduction problem? model
reduction problem is actually
trying to determine Have a
replica of that, you know, fine
scale model that one can have
outputs, you know, almost equal,
right outputs almost equal,
right? And the machinery they go
through to do that, it depends
upon if you want to do physics
based if you want to do data
driven, and so forth. Okay. So
what is the approach that we
have taken in the past? Okay,
the approach is there is the
classical approach of projection
based model reduction. And
that's basically if you have a,
an equation like this can be a
reservoir simulation, it can be
the reservoir equation, right?
We assumed that we can project,
right, these states large scale
system states into a much
smaller subspace right here,
we're using this V, which we'll
call projection, right, and we
can project this that, you know,
the classical approach, and we
can get a reducer model out of
that. Okay. And that's the, you
know, many, many people have
have done that we have several
papers on that. But there are
issues with that implementation,
it is that, you know, 111 thing,
one look at this nonlinear
function. And, of course, being
a nonlinear function, one can,
you know, doesn't have a, when
you project this, you still have
to go back to the full scale
system to actually solve the
system. And this somewhat being
fixed with a discrete input
interpolation or some kind of
interpolation in that knowing a
space. Right. But the problem as
well, it is that there is a
separate issue, there is no
output information used on this
on this translation here. Okay.
So that's one thing that we're
going to try to fix. Another,
you know, projection based model
reduction is really nice, you
can get really good, you know,
reduction. And, you know, I
haven't tried yet Libran myself,
and I know that you guys have a
good understanding of that. But
projection based model
reduction, per se, it is not a
robust way of solving the
problem. Why? Because here's,
you know, you have a, let's say,
a reservoir, it's a cartoon,
like, with a wells here, there's
X dots, what happens if you move
a well, from a place to another
place, your reducer model
completely breaks down? Okay,
there's no way to know, at least
in the classical approach, there
is no way to handle that the
dynamical system is completely
different. Okay. Of course, I
mean, as well, if you drill a
new well, or if you open and
close these wells, things breaks
down. And the problem is exactly
how to handle these boundary
conditions, right? Because the
boundary if you if you have an
offline training process, right,
and the classical approach, you
know, if you do SVD, right, and
the online approach, the
boundary conditions are
completely different, right? So
we somehow have to some have a
form of adaptivity to do that.
And we work a little bit on on
that, the paper many, many years
ago with Jana Fannia, from the
math department, that somehow,
you know, adaptively, we, you
know, try to solve, you know,
reconstruct that basis, but it's
still, you need a fast solver to
reconstruct the basis and back
then use a multiscale type of
solver. And, you know, it's
nice, but, you know, if you're
gonna go and apply this, for
much larger problems, that may
not be the way to go. Okay, so,
here's an example of a a
classical physics based model
reduction applied to a hydraulic
fracturing process with a cup of
flow and geomechanics. Right. If
you only look at you know, here
we have a well a two wells
actually parallel wells with a
and we tested out from eight to
24 fractures here the 824 is how
many fractures you have in here,
and it takes a Class A take no
snapshots of precious
saturations and this and the
displacement, sorry, the
measurements of the
displacements, and you'll go
through this physics space and
you get a good speed up here.
And you can see that as more
fractured as you get more speed
up that you get exactly because
there is a there's overhead
associated with the process. So
the more accurate you get, of
course, there will be a higher
speed up on the process. As I
mentioned, we if we do some
changes on this, things will
break down and that's what we
want I always in my paper, they
say when he works, it works
really well. Right? And it's
still not too robust yet for for
lots of tweaking and here and
there, okay. All right. So, what
are the existing solutions that
we are looking at and why we are
going through? Okay? So many of
these things have already been
done in our been published,
right? Pod daima TBWA, our
dynamic mode decomposition,
neural nets, etc, that we're
going to talk to explore a
little bit more and lifting
Berlina realizations, okay? Some
of them, they have a good
handling some of them they have
gaps, right? So what I'm going
to show to you in the next,
maybe 20 minutes or so, is a
combination of these
methodologies. Okay, in
particular, you're going to show
Ecco, I'm going to show
something in binarization.
That's basically the title of
the, the, the talk today.
So if you go back to the
reservoir equation, right, on
the PDE equation, you can now
write up a discretize form,
right? And it discretize forms
can be written up on this
framework here that I call a
classical system framework,
right, where ABCD can be our
matrices. And they are not
necessarily constant matrices,
they are a function of the time,
right? And that's part of the
nonlinear problem associated
with this, these equations. But
the question is, if working
write this up these equations by
hand, you solve the problem,
right? It's really hard to do
that, especially because you
have a very nonlinear problems
that you don't know how to you
get to go and get all these
Jacoby, Ian's and so forth,
inside the system. So build it
up this matrix is ABCD. It is
important. And if you can do
that, without accessing the
simulator code, it will be
really nice odd hypotheses here
it is that one going to estimate
those matrices birth based upon
only a dynamic evolution of the
state. And it turns out that
it's possible, it's possible if
you look at what's called
embedded to control, okay, and
embedded to control it is as
follows. If you have a system,
and you have snapshots for your
simulation, let's call this x,
you can go through an encoder
decoder framework. And I'm going
to show what I mean by this
transitions in a minute, right.
And you can get out of this A
and B information of that today.
So it's a paper a couple of
years ago that use that for
reservoir simulation. And we
thought, well, that's really
nice. But we have if we don't
have information about the
output, so what we do with that
output, might want to can
reconstruct the output by going
through a piece of an equation,
that's great. But if you have a
optimizing things that are
closing and open wells, that may
not work too well. So what we've
done, we took that to one next
level, and we developed a D to C
O and observe, observe here.
Okay, we're in the following
way, we now are creating not
only a, b, and then in that in
that equation here, but we're
creating C and D, as well, as
you go and train does not does
not work. So going through these
networks. Just go a little bit
into details. I mean, the
network itself can it's in the
paper, okay. But one can create
a network with transitions input
and output, state and output,
whereby one look at, you know, a
series of dense layers, batch
normalization value, and the
output A, B, C, and D. That's
really nice. We tested you know,
a small problem here with a
training with the this
particular we have several
wells, in particular, you know,
input to the system, right? And
you get a good, really nice
output information here. I can
go into details later on, if you
if you want me to go through
this, how we actually
implemented this. But as far as
the training goes, if you have a
good implementation of an GPUs,
in our case, this is a small
system it took us 38 minutes
right now for some if you go to
bigger bigger problems than for
training purposes, that might be
much larger timing for for
training. But the nice thing is
that if you compare the high
fidelity simulation here on the
left with this Ecco right at At
least visually speaking, you can
say there is a really good
matching. Right. But as far as a
matching the well rates, that's
even better, right? You can say
that, you know, the high
fidelity simulation here is the
black one. And the, the green is
the TCO. And if you look at the
reconstruction, that's called
Proposition one here, the
reconstruction are for using
abysmal equation. It's a little
bit far off. So we think that
our methodology, it's a little
bit better than just
reconstructing the, the, the
piece of an equation, right, and
especially when you open and
close wells. And then we handle
we also run some statistics that
one can look at this on the
paper as well. And ATCL always
get a little bit better. In
running this many, many times, I
always get a better, you know,
error, as compared to the just
reconstructing by abysmal
equation. We took this a little
bit farther and say, Well, can
we do a 3d model? Can we do a
bigger model? And the answer is
yes. But if you look at our 3d
models, that usually they have a
no active grid blocks, write D
to C, or D to co cannot handle
that in some ways, because you
need a some chi square
architecture or a rectangular
architecture, right. But we are
able to handle this with a
partial convolution layers,
right? They can explain later on
if it needs to. But here is the
solution for this ag model. With
a with our E TCO that we have a
paper in preparation that was
going to show all the
demonstration here and the
timing. So hopefully, that will
be published soon as well. So
that's great. I spent maybe half
an hour or so to talk a little
bit about that. But let me move
on to the issues that we
encounter as doing it to co
write and, and one of the
issues. Was that exactly on the
nonlinearities. Right. And as I
said, many times you get, you
know, things to work, when times
you get things not to work,
especially if you go from the
classical model reduction to a
little bit on this, etc. Oh, and
etc. Oh, by the way, it's a it's
if you look at the word
implementation, exactly
trajectory piecewise
implementation with a proper
orthogonal decomposition
embedded into it. So but the the
proper orthogonal decomposition
get on using this encoder
decoder framework, right. So
there is still some issues with
nonlinearities. And one way that
we sought to solve the problem
was to look back what we've
done. And now maybe six, seven
years ago, on writing up the
nonlinear equations into what's
called a bi linear form. Okay,
back then, we wrote this by
linear form. What I mean by that
if you have a full order system
here, the same way that we had
before, we can write this up
into this biding their form
right here, this Medina form,
which can get us a little bit
better handling on the
nonlinearities. The thing is
that in when we published the
paper, we wrote that
binarization by hand, okay, and
as you're gonna see, this
nonlinear is a linearization, or
does binarization depend upon
augmenting the states? Right? So
if you have states x to be order
of n, right, when we go to these
states, here, on the Ballina
form, you're actually almost
doubling the number of states,
right? And back then, if you
look at the paper, right, we are
not able to solve much larger
problems. We had a very tight
example was very nice,
theoretically what we wrote, but
we hit at that time a wall say,
well, we cannot proceed further.
What happens in the last five,
six years was the development of
this notion of the Koopman
operator, right? I did the deep
neural net basic mobile
operator, and I'm going to show
you the next slide, what a
basically Koopman operator, and
the Cooper operator allows you
to go to a node does
binarization in a much cheaper,
cheaper way. Okay. And that
basically what we are proposing
we're proposing to go from this
loneliness system to a Koopman
operator, writing up as a body
in a form and then operating on
this body in a form and creating
projectors to do that. This
model reduction step, okay. Of
course, this is not so easy,
right? Otherwise, we'll be
really happy Right. And I'm
going to show in the next slides
what what issues we encounter
doing that and how we actually
fixed some of the issues. Okay,
so but anyway, so the idea is
actually writing up a Koopman
operator to binarize the system,
and then the projection on the
fly using this projection
matrices fi and cy. Alright, so
Koopman operator, a couple of
theory is not new. It's
something that, you know, was
developing the TARDIS and
basically, it is
trying to write up this new set
of coordinate systems, so that
you can kind of somehow
linearized the system, right, so
you write this up into a higher
dimension, state space, that you
can see a linearization out of
that. So here an original
manifold. And thanks to the
papers here by Nathan and cuts
in Brunton, they'll move down
from the the theory, only the
theory to actually something
more, that's really efficient
computation, okay. So, we can go
from the original manifold to a
flat manifold using this Koopman
theory. And the classical
example here, not spend too much
time is actually looking at this
od e, if you have this od E,
which is nonlinear, if you can
find this operator, sigh here,
whatever the operator is, right,
and introduce this operator into
your dynamical system. Okay, one
can look at the new equation
here in the bottom, right, as a
linear operator. Okay, it's a
linear operator. So that's
basically the idea, right? But
finding this function, finding
this function, it is the hard
thing. And that's what, you
know, prevented us from moving
on from this paper to do
something else with that, right?
We didn't know how to do it,
right. So, so, how does the How
does it work? Okay. So, imagine
that you have a full simulation
here, right? And you run the
simulator using your equations,
whatever, whatever you have, and
then you save up the states
Okay, say about the snapshots of
the states. So, while one does
for determined the Koopman
operator, it is as follows. You
take these snapshots, you run
these snapshots through a series
of networks here, deep learning
networks, okay. And not only
that, you have a encoding
process here, that you go from a
high order space to low order
space kind of going doing a
projection, right, if you look
at these encoding, is basically
doing a projection. Okay, so you
you train this network, using
the states such that you find
the Koopman operator, but at the
same time, you find the
projection matrices, sigh and
fees here that we were going to
use to project the system. Okay,
of course, you can look at this
is just a garlic garlic Galerkin
process, you can do Petrov,
Galerkin, that's the same type
of experimentation, right, but
one goes to this network and
train this network and find this
V and find these projection
matrices that you have now, a
set of coordinates in the latent
space and the A matrix is
actually read read up directly
from this network. Okay. So let
let me so that's basically the
the Koopman operator process. So
let me show we implemented this,
we start up with a very
simplistic case with a bottle
levered, right, which highly
nonlinear and nonlinear in some
sense, and has issues.
Especially you're going to try
to apply this to the physics
inform neural net framework.
Right. So here's our equation.
If, as I mentioned, if there's
some work on trying to do this
in the physics inform neural net
framework, right. And of course,
I mean, the classical approach
for handling a book elaborate is
to add up this artificial
viscosity for stability purposes
right. So if you add up this
stability parameter for you can
guarantee stability of these
these book elaborate right this
additional office stability has
been solved by having another
Now this slide is a A flux and
chill IP that developed some how
to actually introduce this
artificial viscosity, right
using a pin. But here, we try to
solve using what we call a, we
turn these into learn a
learnable parameter. So I'm not
going to dwell too much, that's
not the point here. The point is
that, you know, the bottle
average has stability issues,
one can fix using a learnable,
parameter learnable viscosity.
Alright, as you can see here,
okay, we can see those, you
know, by using adaptive learning
learnable viscosity, we can
actually stabilize the system.
But the using the use of Koopman
operator can also stabilize the
system. Okay, so here's the,
here's the, the solution. Okay?
So if you say, you know, varying
boundary conditions, using this
framework for the Kuiper
operator, right? What can
actually stabilize the solution
of this book leverage? Okay, so
that gave us a little bit of
hope, on how to explore this for
much for single phase two phase
and multi phase flow, right. And
that's the solution here. And by
the way, so the, if you look at
just the bottle average, I know
they're comparing, you know,
this may not be a fair
comparison, given that our proxy
was done in a different
framework in the different
platform, but just look at, if
you have a 1000s of simulations
of a book, elaborate, may take
1.2 hours, in our case, using
these Kanban process, it takes
2.3 seconds, just to keep these
into perspective. Okay, so now,
going a little bit more for two
phase flow, right, we apply this
for going for two phase flows
here with two producers and one
injector. And let me show a
little bit what the the issues
were developing this for a much
larger problem. Okay, as you're
gonna see, there are actually
not only five oh, this is part
of the training process. And I
think I forgot to mention,
right, how they actually train
this, right? You trained by
based upon a introducing loss
functions into the process,
right, to guarantee some, some
matching of the states and
outputs and other things, okay.
As you're gonna see, the process
is not yet efficient in the
following way, you still have
lots of loss functions that we
have to deal with. Right? And
not only five as written up
here, but you have actually, the
whole framework, is that
actually eight loss functions,
and we don't know what to do
with them, you know, to be
honest, right? How do you
combine them up into a much,
much less a number of loss
functions? But the idea here is,
is that on the training process,
right? Wanting to reduce the
loss function for the auto
encoder, right that we want to
match up the state. We also want
to match up the the coupon state
and Latin space, right? And we
want to match up the prediction
in X and other things as well.
Okay, so those are the last
functions that one has to
guarantee to, to make the
student to work. Okay. When we
showed that we actually, we hit
a wall. I mean, there was a
Marcelo de la kortesis, here at
a&m A year and a half ago, we
hit the wall. Well, we cannot do
it. Why? Because, again, coming
back to the problem of having
controls and output, right, if
you write this up the for the
coupon for function for the
reservoir simulation equation,
there is always a term here,
right. And it's a simplistic,
you know, differentiation here,
but it is a term that is a
nonlinear in control that we
know how we don't know how to
handle that. Okay, so we started
for nonlinear system, we could
potentially discover the Koopman
operator, but there's always
going to be a nonlinear function
here that cannot be
discoverable. Okay. So at that
time, we hit the wall, like
maybe a year and a half, two
years ago, and all of a sudden,
Marcela was very diligent,
diligent, and found a solution.
Okay. And the solution was the
following. There was a paper
here 2021 that talks about the
following. If you have a system,
a nonlinear system, that is
controller fine. Why don't we
control a fine if you can pull
out the control you in this
particular form. Okay? The
system can be by linearized.
Okay, that's the paper. That's
basically what the paper tells,
if you have a system that is
control control a fine, right?
The system can be by linearized.
And how do you by linearize, you
apply these to the control. I
mean, there is a process here in
place. But basically what you
find, instead of finding just a
matrix, you find n and B matrix
in this way, a n and b matrix A
here.
So, that's exactly what we did.
We took that and we bind in our
eyes, based upon the guarantee
that one can do that, given the
fact that reservoir equations
are in this controller fun way.
Okay, so here's the solution.
Applying this to a controller
find perspective and Bollinger
eyes, the with the controls,
here's the solution. Using to
know, again, you know, at least
from you know, inspection, you
can see that the proxy model can
handle really well, the
saturation France and
everything, especially for very
well rates. Okay, very well
rates. But that's not
necessarily the the whole story,
because you might end up with a,
a matrix, that it may not be
necessarily stable. Okay. And
that's what I meant that there
are lots of Allah's functions
that we added up to make this a
little bit more robust. Okay.
And one way that we handle this
A matrix not to be stable, we
basically said, instead of
let's, let's say the A matrix is
small matrix, right? It's, it
comes into Latin, it's formed a
Latin space, so it's a small
matrix. So we can afford to
calculate the Eigen values. And
what we do, if we have Eigen
values that are outside of the
unit circle, right, we clicked
them off, we clip them off. And
luckily, that didn't happen too
often. But there was a
particular loss function that we
introduced to clip that, or to
to guarantee that you'd have a
stable solution for the A
matrix. Okay, again, remember
what I mentioned, we have too
many loss functions that we we
don't know yet how to combine
them together. Okay. But anyway,
so, if the system are stable,
then they can see that matching
the results and the well
locations are really good. Okay,
with errors, you know, point 4%
point 4% for water saturation
and pressures. So we really gave
us hope to do that. Okay. Now,
the second issue that we
encounter, right, is as follows.
That's great. We can do that.
And I'm, I'm about to stop here
in maybe a couple more minutes.
That's great, we can find this a
n and B's, but that depends upon
how actually initialize the
system, okay. So, you given a
seed for that training
stochastic process depends upon
the how we actually train you
may get not so good results,
okay. So, we Marcella had a
second contribution here was as
follows why don't we use what we
know already, which is a DMD
right to initialize with a very
few snapshots, we initialize a
and b given already the you
know, proper snapshots of the
system, okay. So given proper
snapshots of the system, okay.
We can initialize the a n and b,
okay, using this idea by linear
mode decomposition, okay. So the
if you look at the paper, one
can look at Berlina
realizations, right? And one
can, no reason, create in a very
efficient way, a very initial
value for A and B. Okay, I'm not
going to go into details on DMD,
Berlina DMD but one can do that.
And so what we call a stepwise
training process, we we train
the encoder, then we create, we
use a few snapshots of the
states, we initialize a and b
and then we with that initial
states A and B, we train all
together for the final result.
Okay. And as a comparison here,
again, one simulation 45 seconds
for that model. And if you have
a 220 there was the dataset that
we had. It took us four hours in
the MRS See, but as opposed to
40 seconds in our, our framework
with really good, stable results
and robust results. Okay, so
some remarks here, and then I'll
close down things that are, you
know, entirely build on I states
snapshots and, you know, we add
up output information. And we
are able to reconstruct the
surrogate, doing, you know, this
idea of Biden or recession.
Okay, one thing that we're
working on at the moment, it is
as follows. We can, you know, if
you look at the control theory,
right, the balanced rotation, it
is actually a better model
reduction, working for at least
for linear system, right?
Balanced vacation, it is the way
to go for if you have input and
output, that's what our main
objective, so what we are
working on, is actually
translating this, this framework
into this bio balanced
application framework. Okay. And
I'm gonna skip some of this.
Okay. And the balanced location
framework is actually a
something that looks at
controllability and
observability, right? It's
really good for linear systems,
and basically translates to find
this controllability functions,
peace and observability
functions cues, okay, that
identify states that are easy to
control, and observer
observation that are difficult
to to measure. Okay, so if you
put this into perspective,
right, they're called
grammarians, and we, if you look
at the equations, one look at
how to calculate those
graduates, right. But in the
end, it turns out that, for our
case, for taking that framework
for doing balanced rotation,
it's just a matter of adding
warmth or loss function. Okay,
one more last function, which is
minimizing the trace of these
two equations here. Okay. And we
have a paper coming up that
talks about that, right. But
basically, that's the solution
here using balanced truncation.
Okay. And one can say that you
get, you know, really good
results with balanced
truncation. Anyway, so that
input output perspective that
can match really well input and
output. Okay. So let me just
conclude here, we propose in our
summation for a nonlinear system
to more amenable form he to co
piecewise linearization. But in
our form, as I said, we have
used several loss functions too
many to be honest, right. And
hopefully, that we will be able
to fix this in an in the near
future. But the nice thing is
that we have the addition of the
output information, which may be
really important for some, some
implementation in some
applications. Okay. As we speak,
in our Marsella, had graduated,
so I have another student now,
taking these up one notch, and
doing this for CCS. So
interesting how to
implementation for carbon
capture. So hopefully, we're
going to do that, and have
another student looking at
possibilities of using transfer
learning one, boundary condition
changes, okay, exactly. When you
when you open and close wells
when you move well, locations,
how we actually, if you're gonna
do optimization for, or, well,
location optimizations, how
actually one can handle these
into our framework. And finally,
as I mentioned, I haven't tested
Libra myself. And I'm eager to
get my hands dirty, and get
maybe some of these
implementation into Libra. So
with that, I'm gonna finish
here. I acknowledge some of my
collaborators, as I mentioned in
the beginning, and some of the
funding here. And I'm open for
questions and answers and
anything that you want to want
to know from the from the from
the implementation. Thanks so
much. Yeah, thanks for
a wonderful talk about the
golden retriever. We look
forward to the collaboration of
using LeBron on the digital
twin, especially in the arts of
surface applications. Yes. Now,
we don't have any questions in
the chat room yet. If the
audience have a question, please
raise your hand or feel free to
unmute yourself. So, while we're
waiting, I may ask some
questions. So I'm curious about
the potential challenges of AI
Applying, say the easy to
approach to more complex or
real, realistic reservoir models
like conversational reservoirs
or play or models. So, with the
auto encoder be very difficult
to train in such large state
spaces.
Yes, that's actually one of the
main issues. I mean, the the,
the training process is actually
the main issue, right. I mean,
it's not necessarily the the
training process, but the, the
computational time involved in
the training process, right. We
are testing some of our
framework for larger problems
using the High Performance
Computing here they nm and in
takes several hours to do that
to the training. Right. So
that's something we're looking
at a ways to reduce that timing.
But we don't I don't have a, I
don't have a silver bullet to
tell you what to do.
I see. So I'll just curious, I
do think that you see too, or is
it you Oh, framework will work
if we simply use linear
compression in the state space?
Because I mean, it is more easy
to.
So if you look at, you know,
linear compression meaning, like
doing an SVD Yes, right. Yes,
yes. Yes. Now, right. I mean,
the outer encoder is actually a
is an SVD. framework, if you
will, right. I mean, it's a pod
like, right, and we, we use the
classical approach, using pod,
we've done that, and we showed
that we can do that. But again,
it has robustness issues, right.
And then deciding on a number of
reducer states is not
necessarily if you follow the
recipe like, you know, get the
energy function and occurred do
a cut off. That doesn't work for
for some reason, that doesn't
work for much more complicated
problem. Right. So I believe
they said is, there's a much
better way to to do that, that I
don't know.
We have a question. I can ask
questions. You know, the frame
of view introduced first to the
auto encoder, and then fit the
latent space data into, you
know, there's a specific form of
TMD. In the later part of the
talk,
right.
I was wondering how you
parameter rise that framework,
maybe I missed that part.
Probably explain that. Because
you you do have some parameters
to tweak, right. I mean, there
is a source locations or, you
know, whatever the boundary
conditions are initial
condition, whatever, you're
changing that your model has to
be robust in parameter change.
Right. How do you deal with
that? Mistake?
The things that I presented
here, we have a fixed fixed
system. Right. What I haven't
shown here is actually the the,
the parameterization. Right? We,
we don't have a we are working
with, you may know Jim Ragusa.
Yeah. Right. Yeah. So so we are
working with the John reducer to
actually do these interpolation,
the parameterization
interpolation, right. And the
decline in the classical way of
model reduction for for at least
for reservoir simulation. One
can parameterize the, the well
locations by looking at
distances. And we had a paper a
couple of years ago on doing
that. It works somewhat. Well,
right. But it's not, it's not
robust again, right. But we are
hoping that this collaboration
region reducer will lead us to a
little bit better, better we
have no interpolation.
Yeah, he has, he has published
some parameters with DMD
framework recently. But you may
also want to check our recent
paper on latent space dynamics
identification papers, I can
send two of those and both of
them talking, talking about the
parameterization and also, you
know, when you do the
parameterizations, you need to
sample to two To decide where in
the parameter space you need to
generate the data. So all those
things, those. We'll be glad to
take a look at Yes, yeah, yeah,
I can forward it to you. Yeah,
sure. Okay, yeah.
Sounds good. So I don't see any
more questions. So if that's the
case, let's find started you
then again for sharing his
excellence research with us.
Thanks so much. Thanks for the
invitation, and I'll be glad to
collaborate more